I unfortunately today have to tell you
about arguably the most dangerously
belligerent comment we've seen so far
from the president-elect and there's
been no shortage of dangerously
belligerent comments so to say that this
is at the top of that list really says
something I reported to you I think it
was last week about Donald Trump turning
down these daily intelligence briefings
like no president-elect has done before
and he was actually asked about this
over the weekend during an interview on
Fox News Sunday we've now seen tweets
about this we've seen responses from
President Obama so we're gonna walk
through the entire thing and I'm going
to explain to you why this is so utterly
disturbing let's start with Donald Trump
explaining that the reason he doesn't
need intelligence briefings every day is
because he's smart you are getting the
presidential Daily Brief that's only
once a week well I get it when I need it
but is that if there's these are very
good people that are giving me the
briefings and I say if something should
change from this point immediately call
me I'm available on one minutes notice I
don't have to be told you know I'm like
a smart person I don't have to be told
the same thing in the same words every
single day for the next eight years I'm
like a smart person this misses the
point especially particularly with Trump
we know that he really only keeps
present in his head the most recent
thing he's heard or was told so it's
extra important that even if he's being
told the same thing every day that he be
told the same thing every day however it
is insanely unlikely that he is being
told the same thing every day when we're
talking about intelligence briefings
that deal with billions of people on
this planet over a hundred countries the
odds that the intelligence briefing is
the same every day or almost zero that's
what intelligence experts have told us
this is so dangerous Pat on so many
levels yeah I think most people who are
intelligent try to express that in their
words in their work you know Trump just
goes out there and says I am very smart
person and generally speaking the peep
that we most consider to be really smart
people aren't also the people that go
around talking about how intelligent
they are I've met very few truly smart
people Pat that will remind you about
how smart they are now as usual the
trumpets love this because they say he
know he's doing his own thing he's not
gonna waste government resources and
time is gonna be making America great
again but America has elected a
president who can't be bothered to do
the work of the president part of which
is being briefed daily and situations
staying the same actually is news so I
also want to talk about how that makes
no sense Trump saying if things are the
same I don't need to be briefed again
now I've already told you intelligence
experts say the daily intelligence
briefing how could it possibly be be
exactly the same maybe Trump thinks it
is but it's not even if it were the same
on consecutive days that is part of what
it is important for the president to
know if you have certain intelligence
situations Pat that aren't changing from
one day to another that is in and of
itself news and do you news that the
president should be aware of yeah we
know the consequences of a president
ignoring a daily brief before 9/11 the
month before yes george w bush was
warned that osama bin laden was intent
on striking inside the united states his
whole team just ignored that memo and
we've interviewed richard clark in fact
the the one of the authors of that memo
and we know how that was a warning that
went unheeded by the bush administration
i started wondering is there any
evidence at all that there is something
special about trump that does in the
real world explain why he shouldn't be
taking the daily brief briefings and
there isn't there just absolutely isn't
what might be going on is that Donald
Trump isn't smart enough to realize that
these are not the same reports every day
because as the ghostwriter of his book
the art of the deal told us Tony
Schwartz Trump has no attention span and
probably hasn't read an entire book
cover-to-cover in the last 40 years but
I want to go even further never far
behind is a hilariously embarrassing
contradiction when it comes to Donald
Trump and of course not surprising to
many in our audience Trump Oh
pined on Twitter stated it as fact even
though it's not in September of 2014
that it's a bad thing that President
Obama isn't reading his daily briefings
if we go back to this tweet that Donald
Trump sent fact Obama does not read his
intelligence briefings nor does he get
briefed in person by the CIA or
Department of Defense too busy I guess
of course that wasn't true that was
based on a dubious report from the
Government Accountability Institute
which was co-founded by big coincidence
Steve Bannon Donald Trump's in coming
very close advisor and Breitbart news
CEO so not only is Trump's explanation
for not receiving intelligence briefings
laughably bogus he wrongly slammed
President Obama when he believed Obama
wasn't receiving the briefings you
cannot write this stuff and President
Obama has now commented on this Pat
saying quote it doesn't matter how smart
you are you have to be the you have to
have the best information possible to
make the best decisions yeah and even if
you are some really smart person you
should still be taking in new
information I mean this whole story
would be funny if there weren't some
serious consequences at risk here this
is not funny you know and you know I
know that it's it's the subject of lots
of internet articles but there is
nothing funny about this we've got a
president who can't be bothered to do
the job the president needs to do and
believes because of his self professed
high intelligence that he doesn't need
to receive these briefings this is very
very very dangerous stuff meanwhile our
friendship with Russia in a way that is
going to get Trump played like a violin
continues to grow and we'll talk about
that later and have been talking about
it